a lot of misconceptions a lot of false
notions that are out there
being pop propagated about islam and
muslims
and it's based on illogical fallacies
on things concocted by people who have
no idea what they're talking about
and some genuine sincere people who have
just been
stooped and misinformed and i want to
go ahead and start off with one incident
where i was speaking with someone and i
was
sharing with him many of the
commonalities like first off how we
greet each other peace be with you
assalamu alaikum we're people of peace
spreading peace and purpose
and this is how jesus greeted his
followers with and
talking about the deep love that we have
for jesus we can't be the antichrist if
we love christ
and christ is jesus the messiah he was
calling people to worship the creator
not the creation it's an article a
tenant of our faith so i'm
telling all this to one christian uh
brother
and he said well isis likes jesus too
then right
i say oh that's interesting i said the
kkk likes them too right
so they have those big jesus saves and
but they don't represent christianity
and nowadays what's really
propagated in the media and constantly
been thrown out their daesh isis as if
these people represent islam
they have a very you know they've
drifted away
they're killing more muslims and what do
you end up
responding to when you get this question
that's out there about this uh people
attributing islam
to people such as these
extreme elements that are out there so
this is a very common question that we
get all the time because this is
something that is
you know being um shown in the media
over and over and over
so the thing is that the the thing we
tend the way we go to tend to ask the
answer this question is as follows
if if something or somebody does not act
like who who claim he is then he's not
that person again
for example if something does not look
like a chicken that's not like
walk like a chicken does not uh does not
have the feather like a chicken that is
not a chicken
so the same thing you know if somebody
you know who does not act like a muslim
who does not function like a muslim
who who he could claim he is he's a
muslim
you know up and down left to right and
center but if he does not
act like a muslim then he's not a muslim
you know so this is a very
you know something that we we tend to
make the people realize of
you know not everybody who claim he's a
muslim then he or then he's a muslim
again that these people are
nothing but a small fraction
of what islam and muslims are the
majority
here 99 of all muslims have denied
such actions they said these these
things does not ex
represent islam whatsoever you know so
and
actually the basic principles of the
quran have taught us of something
against them
against that in which allah said
that whoever have given saves the lives
is he has saved
the lives of all of humanity you know um
i think i mean the real threat is i mean
you know yes definitely these these
these groups
are terrorist groups and you will see
many many many
actually the majority of muslims have
denounced these people they're actually
killing more muslims yeah i mean
on the underground who is fighting isis
muslims
who are being killed mainly by isis
are muslims so we are taking most of the
casualties
us muslims um and we are the one who is
denouncing
denouncing them but even but in america
we have
i think we have a much of a bigger
threat
than isis uh that that we claim
that that i mean that exists you know
for instance we have
we actually it was kind of ironic that
you know it was
almost two weeks ago it was air in cnn
in which a show called under the shades
of america they talked about how many
chapters
here of kka we have here in the ground
in
the united states of america and they
said that
in 2004 there was 56 kka chapters
and in 2016 this year you have 197
chapters of 197 chapters of this is the
christian kkk
and obviously they don't represent
christianity but if they took charge
they'd be lynching everybody who doesn't
agree with their version of christianity
not only their own version of
christianity the different even
different races now yeah i mean they
would
i mean pretty much anybody who is not
caucasian
there will be against him so the thing
is who is considered now a bigger threat
you know yes we we we denounced these
these uh
these uh acts that are done by a small
minute minority of muslims but
on the ground we have even bigger
problems that we need to deal with you
know and this is something that people
need to open their eyes with
yeah a lot a lot of mis misconceptions
here but the facts there's facts and
then there's fictions
you know if you look at the fbi data
reports from
1980 to 2005 94
of terrorist attacks were by people who
didn't ascribe to being muslim
and then also a euro poll less than one
per around one percent
and when you give these facts it's not
fiction it doesn't make sense now that
you have more of a chance of being hit
by your furniture
right uh dr pape who is the university
professor in chicago
he was a he's a terrorism expert he
evaluated the cases from 1980
to current times and over a thousand
different cases and he concluded that
islam had little or nothing to do with
these terrorist ass these
are all politically motivated in the
past few years there are almost almost
about
350 plus mass shootings
in america of all of them they were done
the muslims who have done mass shooting
of all of the mass shooting the 300 plus
350 plus mass shootings the mass
shootings that were done by muslims are
two or three
of all of them so we have a bigger
problem why should we
focus in the two or three people of
muslims who have done these things
and forget about the people who are
carrying guns left and right
and down the street you know and
in the schools in the markets and
shooting at people
you know regardless of their race their
own religion yeah
uh there's um muslims are your friends
not your foes and the facts
are the facts fiction is what's being
propagated to create fear
for a certain agenda but when you meet
your muslim neighbor
people have went down and spent some
time with muslim they say
these people are the most peaceful the
most hospitable the most charitable
people on the planet and this is a fact
not fiction
uh tell us about the story with the
brother who was um
i don't know was it a trump rally or
something and then again
propagating uh something about isis and
what did he respond to him with you
remember
yeah he was saying he was he was telling
him how many
muslim scholars nowadays
promote isis there is nothing
he said find me one credible muslim
scholars like
real known knowledgeable muslim scholars
who promote isis
there is none you're not going to find a
single one who says oh these people are
the way to go none of them they're all
of them denounce
have issued edicts or fatwas against
these people in which they said that
these people don't
represent islam whatsoever so what i
mean if
again if you want to know about islam
then you ask a muslim
yeah and 50 years ago 40 years ago there
was no such thing as these groups
al-qaeda
and isis they didn't exist and
the dr pape who's a terrorist expert
again
little or nothing to do with islam all
of these things are political
which again islam condemns it clearly
and i think anybody who's smart enough
you know to do some research to look
into it
they will see the same things that this
is fiction not fact
and there's fantasy and we got a lot of
movies hollywood bollywood you always
need a bad guy
but islam is not the bad guy as though
some will try to
perceive it to be tell us before we
conclude
why many people they say well why don't
muslims again just
this is a lot of these are just some
silly
things that are thrown out there but you
have a big organization here has the
media ever come to you
because they say where's the muslim
voice why has muslims have not condemned
things like this i think the muslims are
always being condemning these things but
the question is is the media showing
how much we can we are condemning these
things quite honestly
i think sometimes we muslims have to
take the blame for this that we have to
be out there
interacting with the people showing them
what islam is all about and this is
about one of our missions
with ask muslim in which that we want to
to show
the community what a real muslim would
look like they're not
the moogie man that you would see in the
cnn or fox news we are real people
we have kids we love to live you know we
we worship god just like you do
you know we we have families we have
jobs you know you see
you see muslims in all walks of life you
see them as an engineer as a doctor as
a salesman you know pretty much we are
your neighbors you know so come
talk to us you know see what we all
about
and and and for you to know what the the
reality of islam is all about
basically ask a muslim get to know your
muslim make the human
connection and don't be fooled by a lot
of the fiction that's out there come and
learn the facts
and we'll see you next time until then
peace be with you assalamu alaikum
and don't forget subscribe right now